summer is officially here the Sun is out
it is shining in sorry to be a downer
but so are it's the cancer-causing rays
everybody knows protecting their skin
from the Sun is important and most of us
have heard off whole lives that
sunscreen is the best defense for that
but a new study backed by the Food and
Drug Administration has shown that some
chemicals in some sunscreens can
actually penetrate the skin and wind up
in your bloodstream so what does that
mean for you and protecting your skin
this summer to find out we're talking
with not Asian guys she's a
dermatologist at UC San Francisco and
editor-in-chief of JAMA dermatology so I
think this study raises a lot of
questions for people on whether they
should continue to wear sunscreen
so just top-line question is wearing
sunscreen still a good idea wearing
sunscreen is still a good idea a
sunscreen though is just one part of
protecting your skin from the Sun and
that includes seeking shade try not to
do physical activities or activities
outdoors during the peak hours of the
Sun which are between 10:00 and 2:00
p.m. and then using other protective
mechanisms like using hats sunglasses
protective clothing so sunscreen is just
one part of protecting your skin from
the Sun can you tell us a little bit
about what the study looked at and what
it found yeah so the study is a small
pilot study that looked at the
application of four different
commercially available formulations of
sunscreen these are things that are
available at most drugstores they
measured the absorption of the key
sunscreen ingredients in the blood over
time and also after the application had
stopped and what it found was that there
is notable absorption of these sunscreen
ingredients into your bloodstream and
that they reach levels really just after
a few hours of applying the sunscreen
and will stay elevated for almost a day
or two after you stop using the
sunscreen so this means that when we put
sunscreen on our skin it's getting
absorbed through the skin and it's going
into our bloodstream and it hangs around
for a lot longer than the application
and the levels that were found in the
study were greater than the levels that
the Food and Drug Administration here in
the United States uses kind of as a
threshold to do safety testing but the
safety testing has not been done so
really what it's telling us is that
sunscreen gets absorbed into the
bloodstream it reaches levels that are
higher than this regulatory threshold
and
and the safety testing has not been done
yet I think when a lot of people first
read about the study they read oh
there's chemicals in sunscreen it's
getting into my bloodstream Chemical has
become kind of an unhelpfully broad and
kind of scary term for a lot of people
they'll hear it and think oh chemical is
bad and unsafe and dangerous but the
fact is all physical matter is chemicals
right so it helps to talk with specifics
here so what kinds of chemicals did this
study find in people's blood streams
yeah well there's two different types of
sunscreen one type we call mineral
sunscreen and these are literally
minerals zinc oxide and titanium dioxide
they coat the skin technically you could
call it sunblock they also often leave a
very white color on the skin so a lot of
people don't like to use it for that
reason
those have been tested and don't have
any systemic absorption so we know that
those are safe the other type of
sunscreen is what we colloquially call
chemical sunscreens and these are
literally chemical filters that absorb
ultraviolet light and these are the ones
that are in question these are the ones
that that have never been tested in
terms of their safety or their systemic
absorption four of which were the ones
that were studying this in this
particular research article what
ingredients in sunscreens specifically
was the study looking at this particular
study looked at for sunscreen
ingredients a vauban zone oxybenzone
optic Raeleen and a capsule what are
these chemicals actually do inside the
body is that something we know yeah so
we don't we don't really know there's
never been any research article that
have suggested that these chemicals are
doing anything harmful to the human body
there are some studies however that
we've been done in laboratory animals
and of course take it with a grain of
salt because these studies always use
doses that are a lot higher than what
what a person would be exposed to but
there there have been some data points
that have suggested changes to your
hormone levels changes in reproduction
and those have have at least raised the
question of whether or not safety
testing should happen in humans but that
safety testing has not happened yet even
if we take the animal studies with a
grain of salt I think that not knowing
is still an unsettling prospect for
people so the question I would imagine a
lot of people are asking is should I
still wear sunscreen sort of is it safer
to
be exposed to the Sun unprotected or to
use this product on my body that has
effects I may not fully understand yeah
well there's something absolutely
certain which is that the sun and sun
exposure and especially prolonged sun
exposure can result in sunburn which is
unhealthy and also can can lead to skin
cancer that that is that is not in
question in this study I think what's in
question is really about how effective
sunscreen is in in protecting long-term
from skin cancer and melanoma as well as
whether it's safe a lot of consumers
don't know that sunscreens actually
considered a medication and so because
of that usually all over-the-counter
medications are subjected to battery of
testing but that has never been done for
these chemical sunscreens and that's why
this study is so important why hasn't
that been done for sunscreen you know
sunscreens have been around for a long
time and they really preceded kind of
the standard way that we evaluate
over-the-counter medications in this
country and so um you know usually in
history and time we find out that a
medication has some side effect that
might be dangerous to people and it gets
taken off the market now what we try to
do is do that do those safety studies in
advance of the medication coming out
however that hasn't been done for
sunscreen because in large part these
sunscreens predated that type of drug
regulation over time and in fact as
early as 1999 the Food and Drug
Administration asks sunscreen companies
to do these to do these regulatory
studies but for various reasons they
have not been able to see that data what
are alternatives to sunscreen or sort of
ways of supplementing the Sun blocking
effects of sunscreen right now um there
are sunscreens that we know are safe and
these are the mineral sunscreens that we
talked about earlier and those are those
are those are not in question at all and
those have been tested if people are
choosing between chemical sunscreen and
mineral based sunscreen is there a cost
difference there's no cost difference
are they as effective as one another
well as far as we know they're as
effective one of the things that we as
dermatologists are still trying to
determine is what is the effective
dosage of sunscreen I think common sense
would say you want to put it on and we
all know it all rubs off when we go
swimming or when we towel off or when we
sweat it still needs to be
determined whether or not there's a
particular dose of mineral or chemical
sunscreen that is ideal for the
prevention of skin cancer and melanoma I
think one important piece of this study
the stud the research article that we're
talking about is that this is idealized
conditions so the subjects put the
sunscreen on and they sat in you know
climate-controlled environment so they
weren't swimming they weren't sweating
or even moving around and they weren't
actually exposed to the Sun and so we
don't know what in the real world in
under real-world conditions what those
systemic absorptions
are like whether the same or not to
those found in this particular study
speaking of real-world conditions and
the question of dosage there's also this
factor of sort of behavioral psychology
right which is I know there have been
some studies that look at people who
apply sunscreen and think that they're
getting the protection in some cases in
some cases get burned worse than people
who are taking protective measures to
protect themselves knowing that they
haven't applied sunscreen so that's the
real-world scenario is a really big
variable that it's hard to account for
it is and this has actually been shown
in studies people put on about half the
amount of sunscreen as on the sunscreen
labels so that's one important real
world with condition as well and but we
don't actually know whether those
real-world conditions for example if you
just use less sunscreen to get less
absorption whether that would impact its
safety and effectiveness as a tool to
prevent skin cancer and melanoma what
are the next steps for the Food and Drug
Administration so in February of this
year there was a proposal put forth that
the Food and Drug Administration will
really mandate that sunscreen companies
provide the safety testing so the onus
is really on the sunscreen companies not
on the Food and Drug Administration what
are the next steps for sunscreen
manufacturers yeah so the sunscreen
manufacturers are now going to be
required to test their products for
safety testing so that safety testing
will begin with with systemic absorption
so looking to see if it gets absorbed
into the sunscreen and that's for 12
ingredients in this in this particular
FDA ruling and then if there is evidence
of systemic absorption past the or above
the safety threshold that the Food and
Drug Administration has for all it's
common to all medications then that will
trigger additional
safety testing which includes toxicity
studies cancer risk and effects on
things like hormones and reproduction
how soon could this realistically affect
what people see on the shelves at their
local pharmacy or supermarket well in
theory if the sunscreen companies don't
provide this data by November of 2019 in
theory these products could be pulled
from the market I think we would all
agree this would be a very extreme
measure given that we don't actually
have any data right now that they're
unsafe however this is sort of what is
being set up by this current proposed
ruling that being said I think companies
also need time to do this the studies
and likely there will be an opportunity
for them to request extensions as long
as they're working on doing the test and
the testing that's been requested what
is sort of the one big takeaway people
should have from this study it's really
important for people to know that it's
it's really essential for them to
protect their skin from the Sun and
there's lots of different ways to do
that and sunscreen is an important piece
of that so people should still wear
sunscreen if they have concerns about
the chemicals that were in this
particular study they can choose things
that we know are safe including the
mineral sunscreens that we talked about
earlier but the real key here is that we
don't know especially from this study
that the for sunscreen ingredients that
were studied are actually dangerous we
don't know that yet and we do know that
sun exposure is dangerous we absolutely
know that that is that is not in
question yeah well thank you very much
for joining us today
sounds like sunscreen is still a good
idea if you don't want to use sunscreens
that have these sort of chemicals in
them the effects of which are kind of
unfair you have other options and people
can of course stay out of Sun and wear
protective clothing too absolutely